plus ou moins d'europe en fonction des
listes électorales c'est le dilemme
proposé aux français le 26 mai prochain
différents projets pour l'union
européenne présentées par les mouvements
politiques portées par nathalie l'oiseau
la liste renaissance va défendre le
projet d' emmanuel macron avec notamment
l'harmonisation de certaines politiques
sur la défense européenne sur le
bouclier social sur tout un tas de deux
choses il ya des pays qui veulent
avancer
on le voit aussi sur la taxe gafa par
exemple il ya des pays qui ne veulent
pas avancer parce qu'elles ont des
avantages et qu'elles ont choisi d'avoir
une politique
et puis d'autres qui veulent avancer
différemment et donc l'idée c'est ça
c'est d'essayer d'avancer sur tous les
sujets sur lesquels on peut aller
ensemble ou en tout cas à réunir une
majorité face au projet présidentiel les
républicains présente une liste menée
par françois-xavier bel ami avec la
volonté de défendre une europe
pragmatique à travers des projets
concrets à l'échelle européenne
aujourd'hui l'europe elle ne convainc
plus les français parce que elle semble
inefficace parce qu'elle donne
l'impression d'être quelque chose qui
contribue à cette dépossession
collective et donc il faut absolument
redonner sens à l'europe parce que nous
avons besoin d'europe dans la
mondialisation à gauche yannick jadot
porte sa liste europe écologie les verts
dans cette candidature libinois mounir
satouri leur projet un traité
environnemental européen et la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
nous défendrons à sedan dans le cadre de
cette campagne à protectionnisme vert
aux frontières de l'europe
ce n'est plus possible de continuer à
importer en europe des produits qui sont
fabriqués ou aux produits dans des
conditions écologiques lamentable la
france insoumise participera aussi à ce
scrutin avec un programme basé sur
plusieurs piliers européen
1 la transition écologique totale de
l'économie de 1 modèle social européen
qui soit le modèle le plus exigeant
disponibles qu'on puisse imaginer par
exemple avec un smic européen qui soit
au même niveau dans toute l'europe etc
face à ces différents projets d'autres
mouvements politiques sont orientées sur
d'autres modèles d'europe
le rassemblement national avec la tête
de liste jordan bardella défend lui une
europe des nations
elle repose sur plusieurs thématiques en
ce qui nous concerne la défense des
frontières en premier lieu que ce soit
contre l'immigration ou contre les
travailleurs détachés elles reposent
aussi sur la défense
des des français du système français qui
est mise à mal par l'union européenne et
puis enfin elle défend le localisme
c'est à dire la lutte contre une
certaine forme de mondialisation qui
fait qu'on se retrouve avec des ogm dans
nos assiettes même longueur d'onde pour
le mouvement debout la france de nicolas
dupont aignan prenant lui des
coopérations entre les états européens
la france est et la septième puissance
mondiale et n'a pas nécessairement
besoin au niveau de sa diplomatie ou de
son économie d'être porté par un
ensemble plus vaste plus lourds comme
l'union l'union européenne d'autres
listes seront aussi présentés aux
français avec lui des i de jean
christophe lagarde
le parti socialiste allié au mouvement
place publique de raphaël glucksmann le
parti communiste de ian brossât
génération pour un assaut mené par
benoît hamon ou encore lui pr2 françois
asselineau et son projet deux fréq site